[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm
rhett and i'm link this week at the
round table of damn
lighting we yeah yeah we're going to
talk about coinkidinks
yeah we asked you uh what was the exact
wording of the question
um i don't know i don't have it in front
of me have you experienced
a mind-blowing coincidence
a set of circumstances that are
inexplicably wild
like some something you just can't it's
a coincidence beyond explanation
and then my my kind of follow-up
question is and what did you do about it
like how did it impact your life
i don't know you you just hear stories
of people who are like
we lived in different countries and then
uh well i did hear this story you know
this was this is the inspiration for the
question
i just happened to be listening to the
uh
talk radio a while back and there was
some story about
this couple whose parents i think the
guy
was like he fought in the vietnam war
and he he met and fell in love
with a woman over there and then they
almost got married and then they didn't
and then there was no contact at all and
then years later
their kids got married and then it
they realized that their parents
almost got married of course if they did
they never would have existed
right and they would and then getting
married would have been really weird
that's crazy though
and i remember the um we devoted a whole
episode of gmm to that like
we we set a balloon we put a note in a
balloon but there's an incredible story
incredible and i don't remember the
detail we don't need to rehash it
because
it's a balloon that went in the air and
did some crazy things
so we asked brought people together in a
really crazy way for your amazing
coincidences
that um well let me just say before we
uh
oops before we get started uh
that um we don't have any balloon
stories
before we get started we don't believe
in coincidences
i'm just gonna everything happens for a
reason i'm just gonna say that we can
talk about i didn't know exactly what to
expect
uh i'm not saying that my hopes were
high i'm not saying that these stories
are not amazing
especially to the people who experienced
the things but they did not
meet my expectations no i think that
it's a different i mean the story i just
shared about the
the couple that didn't get married we
didn't get we didn't really get
and then get married yeah y'all didn't
give us one of those well but i think so
what we're saying is
you know what scroll through your
podcast if there's something else that
you're like
almost about to choose no i actually
have a point that's not
that's not stick with us gonna encourage
them to like make things up next time
and that is
coincidences are significant
because they are uncommon coincidences
are significant because they are rare it
is not
every day that you find out that the
you know your the parents of you and
your
spouse almost got married in a foreign
country are you
there's you're reacting weird to what
you just said
well i was trying this new type of
coffee that you like you pour a little
coffee in the bottom a concentrate
and then you i added cream and then i
added hot water
and i think it's stratified because i
just drank enough of the coffee
to realize that i have not been drinking
anything but creamer and water
well it's not bad well it's it's going
to be do you need to stir it with
quite a green i was looking for
something to stir it with i looked at
your finger
look back at my finger turn it with your
fingers i looked at the mythical comb
here
kind of early promo i don't want to i
don't want to
do that i could stir it up you could
stir it with the back of the mythical
brush
you know what i'm just going to drink it
it'll stir up in my stomach
okay i apologize all i was saying is
that i'm not
surprised that every single person who
listens to ear biscuits and chose to
contribute a coinciding story
doesn't have some mind-blowing thing
because if everybody experienced this it
would be
absolutely absolutely it wouldn't be
mind-blowing anymore
it would be normal our minds would just
be blown all the time and then
everybody's like a big big deal
big deal that would just be the wind but
that for me this is more a study in
um what when you just ask an
average person what is their most
significant coincidence
it's like oh i see how that is really
significant
uh to you i don't necessarily know if
this is going to
like be like featured on npr but i also
think that um
i think that we can determine whether or
not these are just random coincidences
or actual magic occurred oh because i
feel like
we could be authoritative about that
i'll okay so is it a coinky dink
a full-blown coincidence or just
unequivocally magic yeah yeah right and
when we say magic that's just a general
umbrella term that don't read too much
into that that could mean
the is the universe trying to tell me
something is this
is this a personalized message from god
was it orchestrated or as you would say
was it orchestrated orchestrated yeah
um you know so or was it just
coincidental
hit it let's get started with laura
carlisle i've been with my partner four
years
and we constantly find ourselves saying
the same thing
with the same inflection at the same
time
for example i'll be thinking of
something random that has no correlation
to him like hmm
i wonder how snails mate
and next thing he starts a conversation
on how
snails have sex is it coincidence
have we just got so close let's not call
it snail sex let's stick with the word
mate
when it comes to snails i just don't
think i just don't think it's dirty
enough to call it sex
and i celebrate that there's a there's a
dirty side
i imagine that snail sex is especially
dirty have you ever like looked at a
snail
slimy's not dirty it says you hey they
don't need
any external lube i guess boy
we've done it have we got so close that
we were becoming one
or are we unknowingly communicating
silently
like the way trees communicate and share
with each other through tiny fungal
threads under the soil
well first thank you laura i can answer
the the
your question at the end there unless
you see
lauren's not afraid to talk about snails
sex or
tiny fungal threads unless you see now
first of all what she's talking about
uh is this you know this is incredible
what they have discovered about
yes these these fungal networks that
communicate the trees communicate with
each other several podcasts news reports
articles have been written about this by
this point about this by this point
and the idea that trees communicate with
each other and share resources and the
tree that is in need
of more sunlight we'll communicate with
one that
has gotten more nutrients and like it's
it's all being done
through these fungal networks which are
the largest
living organism on the planet there is
one that
is considered to be i guess in terms of
just like wow
area if you do not see
fungal threads attached between you
and your partner then i am assuming that
that is not what is happening
incidentally that is how snails mate
fungal threads
because they're so slow it was a joke
right i'm not gonna actually i can't
i can't defend my statement well i
actually but no
is that what makes it a funny joke
because they're so slow
like fungus has time to grow on them
while they're either you
thought i didn't it it was more of a
like it felt funny
than you thought funny okay well i think
it's actually still funny then when you
think about it
um bonus this is not magic i'm just
gonna go ahead and say that right off
the top this is not magic
this is just being being if you're
thinking about saying something
and then somebody brings something up
there's something that neither one of
you have seen
have identified that you've both been
exposed to
you know it's so it's a winky dink you
know it's like
you weren't talking about it and it
wasn't it wasn't obviously you you're
not you're not both looking at
snails mating or one snail that's lonely
but you know but at some point
you were you were both exposed to snails
in such a way
that something then a sexy snail sexy
snail and then
something triggered it in each of your
minds
at the same time and so on a
subconscious
you were subconsciously triggered by
something snail sex related
that then when you you have the thought
and you
well and then he had and then he made
the statement
you you can't you're not you're not
drawing it back to the connection but
it's there
it's under the roots it's in the soil
and i do believe good analogy
that snails otherwise known as escargot
when they are eaten
by the french leave it to you to
consider everything in its
in its final food form they are an
aphrodisiac
huh i don't know if that's true or not
but it feels right
so um you're trying to take my joke
thing and
just no no no this is not this is not a
joke
so exactly you're trying to assert
something in the same way that i make a
joke i bet you it'll just feel
funny no i bet you what you said feels
right but if you think about it
it doesn't make sense i'm just giving a
plausible explanation for this specific
coincidence and that is
you guys were no you you didn't give a
plausible
specific explanation you said you
experienced i'm saying give me an
example i'm saying what they experienced
specifically that led to this conclusion
and that is they were watching a program
it's a television show
i call it program in some places okay
and
they were what and it was about uh it
was a nature documentary
and there was something not a snail but
something snail like like a slug that
makes most people think of snails yeah
that was featured they both watched that
right between 48 and 72 hours before
this coincidence then the second thing
that happened was
they both saw something about uh
french cuisine and learn and and
somebody said something in a long list
of things that were aphrodisiacs
escargot was an aphrodisiac or it could
just be something as simple as they had
watched a nature documentary and then
when they were in separate rooms
they were they began as partners often
do began to think about what would it be
like to have sex right now oh maybe we
should have sex that's
one of the things that happens when you
are
in a relationship when you're sexually
acting when you're sexually active it's
like well
maybe we should we should have sex right
now we should be we should activate
sexually right now
and so those things got jumbled up in
the way that they get jumbled up in your
mind before a dream
and they just happen to happen at the
same time
i mean nothing to write home about here
it's just kind of cool that you guys are
in in sync with each other maybe it's a
pandemic thing but i definitely have
seen there's more
there's more of that dynamic it's like
uh
what am i gonna do now i'm at home
like i've always been with the same
people i've always been
one of them's my wife
um this is your thought process
we could have sex hmm
that's how your brain works and then i
send her an email
from a different part of the house
that's just that's how we set it up
okay it's very formal it's like that way
you know it's like you got to both
you you got it you got to sink your
wavelengths
that's best done through email i call it
a naughty gram
i i would think that texting works
better in in this scenario
nice not formal enough okay well my dad
always ends his text with
love dad like with a salutation is that
what they call that
what is the salutation in the beginning
sign off there's an official
where are we going i'm just saying that
you can make a text very formal you can
say dear christy
oh i'm in the other room thinking maybe
we should have sex
sincerely your husband link shanice
lost girl 23 on twitter said not mine
just to get that out of the way but my
parents
were this is kind of like your vietnam
story where flower girl
and page boy now we'll come back to page
boy
to the same wedding because my dad
was the nephew of the groomsman and my
grandmother was friends with the bride
my parents are not related
sweaty emoji sweaty laughing emoji
the only they only realized when they
got married themselves
okay so there's they only realize when
they got married there's no connection
between the two families what about page
boy can we
can we go there is this is page boy mean
the ring bearer uh
i'm gonna say or did they bring a pager
to this wedding yeah
i think it's on a pillow but it's the
pager instead of a ring because he's
like
he was a doctor or a drug dealer uh a
guy getting married was a drug dealer
and
no he's just uh in him to ease emt he's
an emt
i was there i was a ring bearer in my
aunties wedding
you remember it the little no i don't
remember it of course uh you know you
got all the
the the wedding pictures and i had a
pillow
with the with the i guess both rings
were on it
that's a lot to entrust like a a little
child young enough to not remember it
and also like i'd i'd have trouble not
eating one of the rings the way i was at
that age
i would just put things in my mouth i
mean i was like i guarantee i was like
that's for i was four years old how many
ring bears i'm smart enough to follow
the ring every
ring and then oh crap well we have to
delay the wedding how long does it take
a rain to get through a toddler's
digestive system
hmm or do you just have the wedding and
right now let's do it
we'll just do a like a temporary ring
or a pager in this case maybe that's
what happened were you ever
in a ring bearer how many weddings have
you been in just by the way
how many weddings have i been in well
you were in my way
as a child none i was only in my my
aunties wedding i believe
my first wedding that i was in was my
brother's
which might be the first wedding day you
weren't in that wedding well i wasn't in
nicole's wedding you came to it though
well yeah i attended the wedding
i think it was it yeah it was in indiana
we drove to chicago remember that's
right yeah unauthorized that was awesome
yeah we we actually drove to indiana we
picked up your granddad he was
uh he was um thumbing well no
he got it backwards my granddad picked
us up yeah we were we were hitchhiking
we were in
uh rensselaer indiana and my grandfather
my dad's dad
who lived in michigan who we didn't have
the best of relationships with
um i'd seen him maybe once in my life he
decides that he can make the drive down
to uh indiana to see my brother get
married
and link and i had driven a car
from north carolina to indiana with like
age
whatever we were 17. and uh but then for
some reason when we
got there we no longer had use of the
car because somebody else was using it
my dad or call or something
they needed the extra car for something
and at that point
me and you were like let's explain we're
staying in here well and
well well i'm not staying here at the
rehearsal or whatever i'm yeah we drove
to chicago
we did that yeah but i'm saying other
than driving to chicago we were walking
after we got rid of the car we were
walking around
in rensselaer indiana and an old man
pulls up and rolls down the window
and it's my grandfather talk about a
coincidence and i literally have seen
this guy once in my life
and he's like you need a ride he knew
who you were
yeah and i was like yeah we got in there
and he was like
i don't know about this town it's got
more churches than liquor stores
you remember saying that because i was
in the car i don't remember that i
remember like
wow to be rhett's granddad this this is
kind of a
this is kind of a weird interesting
relationship i mean he did i just didn't
i didn't know him yeah but i never freak
i'll never forget that line there's more
he didn't
i don't know about this town there's
more churches than liquor stores
yeah that was how he judges how
comfortable he would be with a town
and after that did you ever see him
again
um i don't know
maybe i don't know i don't think so i
think i saw him twice i think i saw him
once when i was probably like 10 and
then once when my brother got married
he didn't show up for your wedding he
did not
he did not show off i've never even
thought really thought i mean we
literally had
very little relationship with him it's
not like a broken relationship that was
that i used to remember him and it was
broken it was just never it never
happened
so i don't really think much about it
um except for that which we do think
about occasionally yeah right
um if he wasn't in town for the wedding
that'd be one hell of a question exactly
right
exactly oh what are you doing here
but again i think this is a really cool
story for your parents and i'm sure your
parents tell this story shanice
to friends but if you grow up but if you
like if you're connected to people in a
town who get married and then like
well they didn't realize until they got
married that's that's what makes it
weird like
like maybe they didn't live in the town
or they moved away or something or
i don't know but this need more details
to be wowed this is not magic
i mean ultimately what we're saying is
this is just a coincidence it's cool
it's cute and uh your parents
they have a really cool story that they
can tell but it's not magic
no magic occurred here i think this is a
good one jen
everson at jenny white
e or jenny whitey
i don't know double e at the end my
husband and i
went to the same uni uh oh you're you're
british is showing
or i don't know wherever you're your
your non-american use of university
yeah we don't say uni here no we don't
it just yeah
it kind of reminds me it's like saying
like any audi
or uni it's like a third type of belly
button right
yeah my husband and i went to the same
uni
but didn't meet during that time near
the start of our relationship we were
walking past the house i had
last lived in and he told me he had also
lived there
only five years earlier in the same
bedroom
so crazy what a small weird world
well it's not as weird as if he would
have said you know what i live there in
this room and i'm a vampire under the
bed that you slept in yeah right
uh and you just never knew it that's
pretty cool
i mean you get married you have this you
know
obviously you you found this connection
you found your soul mate
and then you realize that you slept in
the same
place only five years apart i have a
theory here
that i think might hold some water magic
it's not
definitely not magic this is all science
um
now you know having uh made an ad for
sleepbetter.org back in the day to try
to get people to replace their pillow
just how many dead skin cells a person
sheds a lot
um okay okay recently
i was watching something and they were
talking about
dust and they were like in your house
if you just go out to a shelf like a top
shelf that you haven't been to in a
while
and you run your finger across that dust
a very high percentage of that dust if
not
most of it is dead skin cells from the
people who live in the house
wow now i just heard that one time and
maybe it's not true that it's the major
but a lot and the number of skin the
amount
of pounds of skin that you shed in a
week or you
there's you just are getting rid of a
lot more of yourself than you
than you realize and every nine years
your entire body is new
every single cell in your body even the
ones that take a long time to like
turn over like your liver cells all
everything is new
so wow while your husband
now who lived there first he also did
five years earlier so
your husband's living in this bedroom he
is just shedding himself
all over the bedroom i mean he he he
will forever he's still in that bed he's
shed in the bed
he's shedding the bed he's shedding the
walls he's shedding the ceiling
your husband is all over this room and
it's almost like
the essence of husband it might be a
different bed i was probably
definitely not the same bedding no it's
not he's the walls but the walls the
walls the floor
but definitely the ceiling nobody dusts
the ceiling oh
and then you go i do into
this room and you live for some
specified period of time
and we already know your skin cells and
his skin cells make a skin cell baby
that's not what happened that then that
you can't get pregnant around like a
fairy and
introduces the two of us now you're
getting into magic
now here's another scientific principle
at play i think we talked about this we
tried to do an episode of gmm about this
and it didn't work
uh it was one of those experimental
episodes where we had different people
wear different shirts and then you
smelled them and decided if you were
like
we tried to guess who it was but it was
based on a study that had been done
which is
based on people's pheromones and sort of
like just general body odor
different people are attracted to
different sort of for lack of a better
word flavor profiles of other people
i don't think that was science i think
it was just some person who we had on
the show who said they could
do a personality profile based on what
people that was different
okay but no but no because there was a
study that was done
where it was like if okay say if i if if
me
as a a heterosexual man who is attracted
to women
were to smell 10 women's shirts that
they had worn
and i rank them according to which one
which smell i was most attracted to
if you were then to show me those women
i might i would be more likely to order
them in my
level of attraction to them based on
what i the the smell
like that's what the study kind of in
general said huh
so what i'm saying is that i believe
that we almost did an episode of gmm
called do white people smell like cheese
we did we did that was pitched to us but
we never did it we did we decided
against that
but spoiler alert we do
jyn what happened in your situation is
your husband had shed
your in the room and you became you
breathed him in over the course of the
time that you lived there
and whether or not you had a natural
connection with that
just exposure therapy being exposed to
the leftover husband that is in that
room over the course of the time you
left lived there
you became primed developed an affinity
yes it's just like when you're trying to
get rid of a peanut allergy and you give
a little bit of peanut
to a person over a period of time so now
it's like her husband is the peanut she
doesn't have an allergy to him
but in the same way that you can get rid
of an allergy you can enhance an
attraction
and that is precisely and scientifically
and definitively what happened in this
case and that is why you're together
today
i actually wonder if it's the opposite
if i wonder if she was still
well if she was still living in the room
when they started dating she would he
would have known that
i hoping it would back me up here i am
going to back you up because
my road dead ended i'm going to be very
fairly quick i'm just going to be very
specific
i mean i don't know if the skin cells
but like oh it is i think it's
like this like
even if it was like a scent thing then
when she's
like there's something about that room
that like a part of him made the room
smell a certain way
and then five years later maybe it still
smelled that way and then
he smell she she smells him and
in real life later and it makes that
it's just another it's a comforting
connection
she smelled seashore seashells by the
seashore
uh we got we got some other ghouls
aren't they gonna be magical definitely
enhance their connection
all right let's let's talk about this
mythical grooming collection
we cannot forget we have totally
revamped
the mythical grooming collection there's
so much stuff that it all can't fit
in the in the high quality canvas
toiletry bag that is available at
mythical.com but if you go inside of
this thing
you talk about lovely scents this hand
lotion
has a subtle version of the mythical
number nine cologne
scent and every time i see this i gotta
put it on because i
i love it's a unisex scent oh man this
one's not open i gotta open it we got uh
now you already know that we got the
beard oil which is now a new packaging
but it's the same formula we have
added to the beard line beard balm
which has got a little bit of i think we
added some um
magic there's some beeswax
yeah we added some beeswax to the to the
formula
so that it does the same thing to
moisturize your beard but also kind of
helps you shape it
still got the oil we got the mythical
pomade and now we've come up with the
mythical
clay pomade uh which uh
for my hair that works perfectly you got
and we've got the purely perfect peanut
butter peppermint lip balm
but now we've introduced a new lip balm
we phased out the uh wooden berries lip
balm because
let's just be honest it didn't taste it
wasn't great unless you like the taste
of wood in your mouth
and uh candy milk so now we've got a
great taste
so it's a little bit more uh palatable
to the average palette
yes it's so speaking of wood sweet and
milky this uh
wet and dry comb brush the mythical
brush
it's made from wood guys this isn't
plastic this is wood
the mythical comb is plastic and it
plays
a tune because it is musical
it plays the gmm things on d d
which part of it does it plays the first
half yeah
i'm gonna give it a try
ah i'm not good at it yet
yeah it takes a couple of tries to get
it down
oh you're pretty you're putting so much
you're trying you're putting so much
pressure on it you practice more than me
it takes i mean it's an instrument it
takes some practice
you could you can get even better go to
mythical.com
here put that in the slot
beep beep beep
worth the wait mythical.com get yourself
groomed up
okay joe scott
i only ever washed my first car
twice both times i did this i had minor
accidents three days later i've never
hand washed
a car ever again now this is not a
coincidence
this is a superstition
this is different this is a superstition
uh it's a correlation but it's not a
coincidence because
you did something and then something
happened three days later
a coincidence is when like things come
together that are completely out of your
control
and that you can't ritualize it
that superstition i agree but do you
when was the last time you hand-washed a
car
um have you hand-washed any not in l.a
cars i don't think i've ever hand-washed
a car in la no
there's so many car washes around it's
like it's part of the economy
agreed back home i mean because they
i mean with the water restrictions they
wouldn't let you just hose down your car
for a lot it's like you can only wash
your car certain days of the week and
i'm like well screw it i just won't wash
my car
unless i'm getting somebody else to do
it correctly i mean i don't want to get
in an accident three days later either
by the way
um i've had i've hand washed
i'll probably hand wash my car
four times since being in l.a do you you
have a brush
like yeah i went on amazon and bought
like a little like twenty dollar
kit that was like a bucket full of like
the thing
um do you like the idea of washing your
own car
no there was a specific reason oh i know
what it was
i know what it was what i went to one of
these
one of the normal washers okay and uh
some of the drive-through washers and
then some are the like you pull up and
you do the spray and you kind of dial in
it's got the brush that the soap comes
out of and then you spray it off
but both of those both times because
they never get completely dry
i got and this was like on a new car
i got those um water spots water spots
and you can see
my car is gray but it's a dark gray your
car is like
light tan or whatever the color is
you probably got water spots you just
can't see them
those water spots drove me crazy and i
was just like
well i'll just wash it again and i go
back and wash it again i was like maybe
it was just something about not drying
no the same thing happened again
and then i'm going online and they're
like well you have to dry it
yeah i know you have to dry it but you
have to hand dry it
yeah i mean yeah so you bought a whole
kit just you could hand dry
no i had to wash the car to get the
water spots off so you bought a whole
kit to wash the water spots off and then
i was out there and
it didn't have it didn't help no it did
and i was like
this is kind of fun playing some music
kind of felt like a california guy you
know what i'm saying like out in the
driveway it's an american it's an
amazing american movie type and i was
very conscious of the
the amount of water i used i didn't use
that much water but i also i mean i'll
pass on this
unsolicited piece of advice i didn't
understand how
important it was for the temperature
for it to not be too hot and sunny when
you're washing your car
i know it seems like something the
california guy wouldn't say
but if it's in the 90s and you wash your
car and
water spots all day long because you
can't get it off fast enough you need to
wait until it's
in the 70s or and you definitely need to
do it in the late evening or early
morning
when the sun is not shining directly on
that stuff so it doesn't dry immediately
i've not changed my work i don't
remember seeing so many car washes back
home
but out here yeah you would go through
the thing and then there would be the
hand washed part
and then you there's like a swarm of
people that just drop
hand dry the whole car yeah you're
talking about taking it to one of those
places that
you get out of the car and it's driven
through and then somebody drives it yeah
i've done that for sure because the ones
that like at the gas station that you
drive through
don't go to that no i'm not saying don't
go to that because of the thing people
worry about with like their paint job is
i don't care about my paint job
but i'm just saying that the drying is
important and there wasn't even a
coincidence involved
cv films at technoboy652
once i was driving in this parking lot
and got cut off
forcing me into a curb which popped my
tire
i started driving away and realized the
tires popped
i like how these in term popped pop the
tire
so i pull across the street into a small
parking lot to inspect it
i looked up and i'd pulled directly into
a tire store
this might be magic
well that's serendipity you know um you
pop your tire and then you
i mean it's kind of like i remember the
one time that i was driving back in
north carolina i was driving from um
holly springs to apex and i got pulled
over by
a cop and i could there was
i had to find the right a bit of curb to
pull over on
and when i finally found it to pull over
the cop behind me the whole time i
looked up and it was the police
department
i was at the police i'll go straight
just booked me now yes
uh i remember that so i know the feeling
it's just like i you know you feel the
need to explain a different feeling
you feel the need to explain i didn't
mean to i didn't even know this was a
tire shop i just
you know it's just here i am well i
think that
this is all about perspective you got
the guy who has
busted his tire popped his tire
who pulls in and he's like isn't this
awesome and this is crazy this is crazy
that it has pulled into this tire place
and the tire guys who work at the tire
plate is like oh there's another guy who
thinks it's a great coincidence that he
popped his tire on that curb that busts
everybody's tire
you know what i'm saying like i think it
might they might have like
spike strips they might they might be
intentional yeah they might be drawing
people in
it might be more than just a curb you
know what i'm saying it wasn't just a
car it might be sabotage
a tire ponzi scheme entire pop and ponzi
scheme
i bet you they didn't do that let's
let's believe the best i mean this is
it is a good feeling here's the thing
that
did excite me about talking about
coincidences coinciding
large and small is
the ex when you experience it there's
like this elation it's like oh
i'm at a tire shop this is so perfect
like this is lined up you know that's
most of the time it's like
inexplicable but for it to be so
serendipitously
service oriented is really nice but even
when it's just kind of crazy like
man we were we were in the same wedding
as kids and now we're married
uh it feels cool it feels cool
right yeah i mean do you remember the
the main uh coincidence that
i'd love to hear again is is the wild
horses one and we can get back to the
tire guy
okay the wild horses story because this
one highlights perfectly
the thrill of experiencing
a coincidence like you may not know the
meaning
but you feel like there should be a
meaning because
it's just so crazy that it happened and
it's a shared experience that when you
tell it it's never as good as when you
experienced it
but it brings up other people's
experiences so you at least you can
share in that
and that's what i want
i don't remember what year it was let's
just say 2005
because it was in the alts okay
i'm with my brother-in-law chris
in a boat at
the north carolina beach specifically
in the sound between emerald isle and
the mainland
near beaufort north carolina okay
this is a new boat that chris has gotten
that bought he bought from his brother i
think
so we're kind of like feeling like this
freedom of like man we just
we got a boat we can go anywhere on this
intercoastal waterway
yeah and that's not like an expression i
made up that's the thing
so we're in the boat and
you know the coast of north carolina
it's got the outer banks
but it's not just the mainland and then
like
you know a long strip of i there's all
kinds of little islands
all around if you look at the map of the
coast right
some are small some are big there's just
a bunch of them and as we're kind of
going through the sound i see
these little marsh covered islands some
have trees on them
and i'm like you know there's a there's
an island somewhere on the coast of
north carolina that has
wild horses on it and chris is like no
i'm like yeah like i i there's uh
i think it has something to do with
maybe like the spanish came over here
hundreds of years ago and some horses
got out now there's like a wild
population like undomesticated wild
horses
that live on some island i was like i
don't think
it's anywhere around here but there are
there are horses there are wild horses
somewhere
so i mean we moved on we started talking
about other things
and then we just start going like he's
like you know
got the pedal to the metal we're just
flying through the sound
you can't hear anything we're playing
the radio the whole time we've been
playing the radio but we can't hear
anything when
we're going full bore and we're going
past
this island and all of a sudden
we look to our right and out from like
behind a tree this
horse like comes up
and like comes up and like
turns away sideways so that like we can
see the whole horse body
wow like it's displaying itself to us
and what did he say
the horse said nothing okay chris
immediately
stops accelerating
and the boat slows down and we're just
idling
and we look at each other like what in
the world and he's like looking at me
like i can't believe this is happening
then
because the boat is no longer making any
noise because we're idling
we hear the song that is playing on the
radio
and the song that is currently playing
on the radio is wild horses
by rolling stones crazy man
that's crazy and then do you remember
what you did you just kind of
you looked at each other wide-eyed right
and you were like are you
are we really here for this right yeah
it was
it was my it's a great feeling it was
mind-blowing it's kind of it's like
it's a strange mixture of what ah
fear there's like a little bit of fear
in it right
it's like you start to feel like is
there meaning
you have a choice is this a puzzle you
have a choice in that moment
and the human tendency is to attach
meaning to it right
sure of course it is questionable what
the meaning would be
you know what i'm saying is like well
what is the what is the lesson from the
universe here
what am i am i supposed to like write a
letter to keith richards i don't know
what like
what is the point we just kind of
reveled in
the coincidence and also with
you know me and you're the same way i'm
also thinking man i've got a hell of a
story to tell
you know what he's like i can't wait
till we get back was it just one horse
because typically there's like a whole
herd well i think we ended up seeing
another one like by
like you know eventually we solved some
other ones
sure want a deer it was a horse and it
was called
shackleford island and that was it which
is known yeah which is known as you
didn't even know that was it and you
were just shooting the breeze earlier
having
heard i had heard like a you know like a
radio
story about it or something but but go
with me here because there is something
to that this
the strange mixture of emotions
associated with experiencing something
you know so wild and so
horselike well there is a bit of
there's aw there's a rush in a rush
that's almost
it feels a little bit like fear like
like you're on the edge of a building
kind of a thing
there's like a physical response do you
think and i don't like to be
like dribble pee in your pants i don't
want to be overly reductionistic and
and to and to say that and i know that
there are some people who try to like
point to the
very specific like evolutionarily
evolutionary advantage that
of meaning making that led to this i
mean and i know
that there is a scientific explanation
for the significance and also the sort
of
mental response that we get to
coincidence
you know us guessing that there's a lion
in the bushes
and there being a lion and there being
a lion in the bushes is that's a good
that's good
like that helped you survive you know
what i mean that's probably overly
simplistic
but it could have it could have
something to do with that that
being able to recognize and attach
significance to seemingly random things
is helpful for your survival but it
could just also be that it just is an
amazing it helps you connect
socially because me and my
brother-in-law have this story
that we'll tell we we will tell if we're
in in the right
place right time you know i mean it is
when chris and i were on our van trip i
think that's
uh again i was thinking of i think there
were there were wild boroughs like
throughout like utah arizona california
lots of little a lot of donkeys running
around um
in those open spaces and it reminded me
of the story you just told
and i was telling christy the story and
i was playing my spotify
playlist and the song wild asses from
two live crew
the song wild horses came on as i was
telling the story
and i had not played it i i didn't
select
the playlist knowing that it was in the
playlist it was a really long
like automatically generated playlist
and it
you know yes i was in like 70s classic
rock
playlists still there's a lot of there's
a lot of music in there so i i mean we
weren't freaking out when it happened
but it
it did give us give me a little boost
you know yeah
it's uh definitely i think i think the
the main thing is when you experience
this
something a coincidence like don't hold
back on the celebration part of it
enjoy it to me that's like that's the
thing like squeeze that lemon
milk it for all it's worth the worth
like
you know just really smoosh the teat
well i think that's
you know i think that's why fine i so
cause like when we you know we'll do
that a lot like what turn things into a
coincidence well that's what i'm getting
fortune cookie is telling us what we
should do with our careers
and then our eyes will get big and we
were like but
well but i'm talking about more than
just that because we don't we were
talking about this we don't remember
what the fortune cookie said but we had
a significant fortune cookie experience
at some point
but i don't know if i'm told this is
never good enough to remember but also
at the beach with my wife's family
not on the same trip but uh with our
friend mike
that we've been camping with a number of
times yeah and we were eating
and uh we had finished corn on the cob
and we had all these
we had all these corn cobs okay and um
for some reason we just got the idea
that we were gonna from the third floor
of the third floor balcony of this beach
house
we were going to throw corn cobs and try
to get them to
land in the middle of the road between
the the double yellow line okay yeah
okay so this equals
littering big a big pile of corn cobs
all over
a road unless
the first one you throw no
rolls hits the road and rolls and comes
to rest
right between the double yellow the
first first one i threw the versatile
mic through
first one i first one mic through and
the first thing is is amazing
mike has been with me for about four or
five
weird things that have happened like
that but what i'm saying is that
you know why then that's the great thing
about mike because
i knew mike would go nuts if it happened
well
but also earlier than that it's like you
know what this is worthwhile
like this stupid idea that
is on the edge of impossibility
is just this is a worthwhile endeavor
you know so i would even
i'm even celebrating that part of it
you've got someone around who's like
you know what this is yeah this is what
we're gonna do
and and there's something about if you
hold your mouth just right
you and if you have if you br it's like
you brought this confidence to it that's
like i know what the experience of that
corn cob landing just
right it would be like so you i bet you
i wasn't there but i bet you set it up
like we're gonna do we're gonna
we're gonna throw this and what you know
you're inventing something crazy like
we're gonna it's gonna land parallel
right in between
you're setting something up that's
unlikely and so that if it if it does
happen it's gonna be awesome
i mean it happened on the first thing
it's like i mean
i assume you erupted in celebration for
a prolonged period of time of course we
did
and then and i also assume you didn't
try it anymore or did mike say
i'm gonna do it i can't remember but
more recently mike came to stay
with us in a house we live in currently
and uh we're like telling the boys
stories about so i can't remember most
of them right now that's the
that's the craziest one but we've done
things like that
usually involving throwing something at
something to see what would happen
i mean that's a long standing tradition
i think
i think it's the from when we were kids
i think it's something yeah
well i did a lot of things where it was
just like i'm gonna throw this rock at
this pole and if i hit it the answer to
this
question is yes it was kind of my magic
eight ball yeah i did a lot of that but
we were telling loch and shepard the
story and then it turned into okay
we're gonna throw the basketball on top
of the house and it's gonna come down
and bounce once and then bank into the
basket okay basketball goal
and uh it did not happen on the first
try but we
committed and we took like an hour and
we finally got it
and because our roof is terra cotta so
you can't predict the balance of the
basketball
it's got a plink so nature anyway
but yeah but i so i love setting that
stuff up just because it's cool
and it for me it's it's about the
connection yeah that's somebody else
yeah it that that's that's the great
thing if you're just by yourself
by yourself it's just a little freaky
you might connect
by telling a story about it later but um
i got nothing else to say about the tire
story let's let's go to
mythical crew members i i guess
kiko put this to crew members or maybe
they follow us on twitter
you know i mean it's not it's not a it's
not
a prerequisite for working for us
but uh hey do you follow employees
because i as a policy don't
um i have so we haven't discussed this i
have a general policy of
not following employees but i realized
that it wasn't always my
policy and so there was a time in which
i
did follow some people and then it's
like if somebody's been with us for a
really long time sometimes i'll be like
maybe i should i don't have a good
policy on this but i probably
should just i should have a policy you
don't follow anybody
that's a policy no i don't
i think my policy is not great because
it can
open me up to uh
favorite it seems like i'm i'm showing
favoritis yeah you got to go in there
and unfollow people
unfollow the people who work for you
okay all right it's like a it's
it's a you know it's a personal
professional
boundary but i mean that being said
you're still being watched and i'm
talking to you mythical crew members
oh yeah right um annelise
producer on mythical kitchen now uh
okay yeah she she
she tweeted a shortened version of this
but i know the complete story because i
watched the
chase hosted good mythical crew
podcast that's exclusively on the
mythical society
and uh annelise was one of the uh
producers on
like people who were fans first and then
became employees that's the episode they
did and i really gotta
i mean you got a kick out of that but
she tells the story of
i and i'm gonna mess it up but um
i'm pretty sure she just moved to la
she moved in with a roommate she did not
know this roommate
if i remember correctly and then she
like
uh she was a fan of ours
and we had we were making that liner
richie
we sing all night long all night long
lana richie's all night long
and at one point even though we were we
were filming it constantly for like all
11 hours at one point we'd go into this
house party
and there's all these people that we
wanted to come out so we put a call out
to fans in the la area who wanted to
show up at like
2 a.m at this house that we were going
to walk through singing all night long
and they were going to start singing
along with us
and that's a big scene in the in the
video and annelise is just a fan
and she's like
oh wow i just i just moved i'm just
moving in
today and tonight is when i'm i gotta go
and she like she's like i know this
sounds weird you're my new roommate
and she like tells her roommate that
she's like i'm fans of these guys
they're doing this music video
so i'm going to be going to this house
party music video thing at like
3 a.m and a roommate's like i'll go with
you
and this was like when they first met so
they both go and yeah she tweeted i was
at rutting links all night long
4 a.m house party 4 a.m playing a kazoo
and now i work for them we did not hire
her that night we didn't meet her that
night
but she you can see her in the music
video somebody had to coordinate what
the
what the crowd would do when we walked
in because we couldn't not walk we
couldn't
yeah there were people there were we had
someone there who was like
organizing the crowd and getting in when
we walked in
because we left the house went into the
front yard and then went out on the
street
and they followed us down the street in
the middle of the night in this
neighborhood
yeah and then we got in a car and and
and kept going
i'm sure we made some people mad as well
annelise is in the video right if you
watch the when you watch that scene you
can see her in the video and then years
later
years later because that was a long time
ago yeah she
she works for us it's quite i mean i
think it might be magic and that and she
did not tell the story
in her job interview which wasn't with
us so it didn't she didn't get any
brownie points for that that's probably
you know what
it's probably wise to not tell that kind
of story in your job interview
yeah like i got a weird call from rhett
and link years ago to show up at a house
at 4 a.m and i did
unless you showed up on a wild horse
read jenna's okay i got to bring this
closer to me because well it's it's
the text is small jenna
who works for us lol
i have a good coincidence story that
guys might like
a few years ago after taking a break
from assistant work for about a year
i thought to myself that i was ready to
maybe assist again
if i liked who i worked for i didn't
tell anyone
didn't tell anyone the next day my best
friend laura
texted me about these two men
uh whose hair and makeup she was doing
for their show
talking about needing an assistant she
threw my name out there
those men were rhett and link first of
all
i just appreciate she's saying those men
you know we get called boys a lot uh
and sometimes guys yeah those men
written link
well that that's part of her you know
her job
told her that she hasn't remember
remember one of the first things we told
her is that always refer to us as men
the men
because somebody needs to
[Laughter]
well this is a coincidence that i'm very
glad worked out in fact i mean she
didn't tell anybody
she didn't even tell laura in her job
interview well
first of all she was recommended by
laura who we trusted and spent a lot of
time with
and especially in like when you when it
comes to having someone
who's gonna be well yeah i was going to
move beyond that to say
somebody who's your assistant um there's
got to be the ability to kind of click
with them
personally yeah and not only they have
to be good at their job but you you kind
of you need to be able to get along with
them
and um laurie just kind of saw
she was like you know who would be
perfect for this and so
that did a that did a lot to kind of
prepare us
for liking jenna and then her
job interview was essentially coming to
the mythical christmas party that year
she was large
as long as plus one yeah and
of course i felt a little bit awkward
about turning meeting her at this party
into her interview but of course you
didn't
no i did i was like i was like what else
am i going to do here
so we kind of conducted the interview
let's get this over in a loud bar
where there was a guy in the corner
doing bonsai because we thought that
would be funny it was kind of nice
because
i mean christy was there for it and then
christy ended up talking to her and
laura moore
and so it was like because jesse and
christy needed to
also like jenna yeah that's that's true
and just like she's gonna be working
with them too
and it all worked out but i didn't i
didn't know that jenna wasn't looking
for
an assistant job until like in her mind
the day before
right and you know what it's worked out
yeah kiko
producer of this podcast who's sitting
behind that
in the glass booth over there
four years ago it was a friday before i
was going to start my new job at
mythical
i had the day off so i hit up my college
friend of 10 years to see if she wanted
to hang out
she told me that she was waiting for a
meeting
with this company that she had been
freelancing for for the past few weeks
and she was going to find out find out
if she was going to be brought on full
time
i got really excited and told her i was
going to start a new job on monday too
i asked what company to which she
responded mythical
entertainment although meggy and i have
had many jobs together
this was the first time where we both
got hired
separately without the other knowing
somehow we can't seem to get rid of each
other
kiko will throw maggie into a story
maggie was in
his ghost story a magic story too oh
yeah yeah
lots of powers at work in uh in kiko's
well i say
based on the the based on the preview
the precedent of the ghost story
that i can't just dismiss this as
coincidence
there could be something cosmic going on
here i think that we just put out
job postings and like they're friends
and they apply for the same stuff
don't minimize it don't minimize it come
on kiko this is not
i mean like you said you've worked
together a lot before it's just this is
the first time you didn't know it
yes but think about it the name of it
this is just name of the company
is mythical entertainment uh okay that
alone
gets you thinking a little bit you're
right two men two there's two men
who who run it
two willow hub
i'm sorry kiko um you know what that was
that was pretty awesome i think it's
awesome
willowhub tweeted at us once i got a
piece of paper and wrote down what i
would say
if i was a teacher i don't know if the
specifics have not been provided i don't
know if that's the result of an
assignment
or like a prompt that class period
the teacher copied my exact
words it was almost like she was reading
my paper
but of course she couldn't because i
still had it i guess
i freaked out and the recess i was super
nervous and then
at home i puked on the paper okay all
right there's a lot here
lots of moving parts wrote down what she
would say if she was a teacher
then the teacher just says what she's
written down
look i i can't i'm having a difficult
time getting past just the first part
of the story yeah right now so like okay
i'm just trying to picture this you are
moving on you want to just move you know
no so
you're not going to figure it out you
got a piece of paper
and you write down what a what you would
say if you were a teacher
and then her teacher said that but this
let's get i can't get past
point one what is happening there what
kind of
if that's an assignment what kind of
assignment assignment is that
it's like the teacher's like you know
what if it's an assignment then that
makes
you write down what you think a teacher
would say
so psychically i can steal it and it
makes my job easier
if it was an assignment then the chances
of coincidence go
up significantly right because
you go like imagine what if i don't know
what grade this was i can imagine what a
like a
a 10th grader might think a teacher
would say no
if this is just a person who is just
deciding
on their own to just begin to write down
things that teachers might say
i don't what's going on there
yeah have you ever done anything like
that have you ever just said you know
what i wonder what a so-and-so might say
i'm a writer i better write it down on a
sheet of paper
never but maybe i should especially if i
find that i have control over what then
someone in that occupation says
yeah if i wonder what the president
would say here's the thing
willowhub if it was a magic piece of
paper
then you puked on it and you ruined it
it could that could have been the
beginning of you living an incredible
life where you could write things on
this paper and then
manipulate what people would say and you
just went home and puked on the paper
and presumably then tossed it i would
say either that may have been your
chance to live an incredible magical
life
or just to be like a script writer
because that's kind of what you think
they say is something that then happens
yeah wow yeah well that's what makes
better that's your calling
so awesome good luck with your stomach
issues though
i just you know what i i think this is a
good stopping point no i think we have
to read the last one
oh we have to make the last puke no we
have to we got to read
something about the the gunk in the
bottom of this stuff i've been drinking
no we have to read the last one because
this is the
i think you just want to say broke back
[ __ ] that is the name of the uh the
twitter account brokeback [ __ ]
okay i was calling you brokeback [ __ ]
fine i call you that too
all the time years ago planning to
intern far from home that summer i
decided to rent a room
online a few weeks before i left i had a
very vivid dream
about being there when i arrived i had a
strong feeling
i'd been in the room before but shook it
off thinking of the dream
i assumed the photos from the listing
informed the dream but
there were other details in the dream
that weren't in the photos
okay for example i opened and this is
all in the dream
i opened the nightstand drawer and saw a
specific book
tangled earbuds folded pieces of paper
in a q-tip used doesn't say
when i was moving in weeks later i
opened the nightstand
to put my things away inside
was that same book tangled earbuds
pieces of paper and q-tip
in the exact same positions as my dream
it creeped me the hell out and i still
don't know what to make of it
and that was the day that i became
brokeback
b the brokeback [ __ ] origin story
yeah i think he's definitely a superhero
but what's the power
uh the power to predict what will be in
a drawer i don't know it's like there's
definitely a wild horse involved
no saddle that's true i see you can
bring it back to wild horses
i haven't seen the movie but i guess
there's like i don't know
i don't know if somebody's gay i think i
think at least two guys two men
um there's something here okay
there's something here now
four objects
i'm positioned in a certain way i'm just
caught up on like open i don't like the
idea of opening a drawer and seeing a
q-tip
even if you can't tell it's been used
but it's a dream just a long
no but then it was real and that that's
kind of that that's
but it's weird it came from a dream now
like why why do you have like one q-tip
in a bedside drawer that's just
that's disturbing like if
unless it was like coated in plastic
like in a plastic baggie
or something do you think this happened
i'm just i let me just ask you that
leave me behind in q-tip land and keep
going with the conjecture because i
don't know what to do with this well
there are two pos there's a number of
possibilities but the two ones that i
see are number one
everything happened as brokeback [ __ ]
has
said it said it did right meaning that
this was the dream in the position and
then she
saw in the drawer these specific things
what are the chances that that is
exactly what happened now
i'm not questioning brokeback [ __ ]
integrity here
because i do believe that broke back
[ __ ] is being honest he's being honest
okay yeah yeah yeah
well i'm just kind of saying i'm giving
her the benefit of the doubt but because
the other explanation
is that in the moment of seeing
the stuff inside the drawer she sort of
projected
what she's seeing now back onto the
memory as she accessed it and accessed
it in a way that made it seem
as if they were the same scientifically
i don't know
i think that's that process i think i
mean
if if there was a purpose to it
or there was some redemptive application
to like and and that kept me from
you know blah blah blah or enabled me to
blah blah blah it's like or was the
first sign of my psychic abilities
through dreams i
you know it's or is there something
about the specific book which again
always all we see is devoid of purpose
is it is it just a specific book or
what is the specific book should you
have taken action should you have taken
the tangled earbuds
unplug them plug them directly into the
end of the q-tip
maybe something would have played i
would have cleaned out my ears with the
q-tip
then put the earbuds in and read the
book
and then used the folded pieces of paper
to take notes on the book
but when you think about i mean
what i didn't want to get to was what
i'm about to say
we're good there's so many you know
anything that can happen
in some point across all
parallel universes does happen all the
winky dinks and
miraculous things that
line up it's just like odds like
statistics dictate that it's gonna
happen
like if if uh you know you've got the
whole
like i don't know the more you study
evolution the more you start to think
that i think about that analogy of like
all these like monkeys typing on a
keyboard and like
you know and if you have enough monkeys
typing then you're gonna get a
you're gonna get shakespeare is that
what it is
yeah but i don't know if that i don't
know if that's true or not
you know okay i mean i mean i'm not i'm
not smart enough to
to figure it out so but um
yeah can you just can you dream random
things in a drawer and then it
it just you know it could happen it
could be a total coincidence it could
could it could it mean something more to
you and it could it be an indication of
some
some sort of appreciate
okay knowledge i have a dream
coincidence but there's no purpose
i've told the story before does there
need to be purpose to it i'm probably
going to get the details wrong
i probably told the story like three
times now but you know the story about
my wife and i dreaming about the same
lot little blonde girl yes yes a little
blonde girl and then waking up at the
same time
freaked out and both of us having just
had a nightmare
that featured this little blonde girl in
my situation she was in an elevator
or she was in a room that an elevator
opened up into and then jesse i can't
remember jesse's situation i told the
story in more detail in the past
and i don't know me and jesse were
pretty freaked out for a couple of days
you know but that was kind of the again
that's sort of the end
of it it it didn't if it didn't keep it
it happened i never ran
into a little blind it wasn't a
revelation of something some connection
or some ability or
well but i do think that i am open to
the idea first of all again i don't want
to be overly reductionistic so i
i am open to the idea that there is
something
that dreams are not just simply your
brain
sort of rearranging itself and shuffling
through your thoughts
as you sleep is that the most likely
thing that's happening
yeah but who cares who's interested in
most likely
right you know what i'm saying it's like
is it is it really fun to just believe
the most likely thing for everything or
is it more fun to believe that
i don't know there's some kind of
connection between the real world and
the dream world and some people have
some insight into that and like let's
lean into that who's going to get hurt
if we lean into that a little bit
i'm interested in that i mean you got
the way that the uh
you know sort of the native people from
australia and the way that they
experience the dream world and i haven't
looked into this very much but
it's very very significant it's
essentially the sort of like the
foundation of the religion as far as i
understand
is the fact that there's this dream
world and um
i don't know maybe broke back [ __ ] like
you know broke through into the dream
sphere and we're just sitting here on a
podcast
talking about it making light of it
saying that it's probably just she went
back and accessed a memory
and and and you know made it up in her
mind
well maybe brokeback [ __ ] broke through
man maybe that's what happened
who are we to say do you believe who are
we to say okay fine
magic i'm open to it
but i have never been scared by a little
blonde girl in real life
or in your dream again she hasn't come
back to the dreams
for either of us if you would have
responded to our prompt
on twitter using your biscuits we could
have been talking about you this episode
so be on the lookout for those follow us
on twitter at mythical
we're going to keep putting out these
things periodically where you can
you can give us stuff to talk about and
then if you want to keep talking to us
and respond to this
use ear biscuits
uh do you have a wreck for us oh crap i
forgot about the wreck
um it's a show on netflix that like i
don't
lily gets into all these this murder
stuff and of course
i never got on the murder wave i never
got on the murderer or the serial killer
wave like i
i'm just i'm not into that like i just
don't you know that's not
i don't like that's too hard-hitting for
me
but i did agree to sit down and watch
because lily talked christy into
watching i am a killer
yeah the interviews on netflix where
they they interview people who are
you know committed murderers and they
tell their stories and then it's
um it the the approach to it is
is mesmerizing and very creepy but also
very insightful i'm gonna recommend
episode one of season two because they
were talking about it so much
that i had to go watch it now it's not
for everybody and if you're not into
if you don't want to stare into the the
dark soul of a killer
through her eyes and like
actually in the i quoted it last week
when i was telling my
you know like uh well i'm not i don't
want to spoil it here
like if i'm not going to tell you the
specific quote because it kind of spoils
the experience
okay um we've watched a number of the
episodes but
uh an amazing i
like presentation of this particular
convicted murderers
story and the way that it unfolds it
really
it really draws you in and gets you to
assess it yourself and make come to your
own conclusions
that's kind of how the series is set up
i don't know that
you want to watch all of them unless
you're really into the psyche of
murderers
but the first one of season two
is uh really great
that isolated episode in and of itself
is just worth watching really building
it up
yeah it's it's uh it's wild i am a
killer
by no coincidence on netflix
all right we'll talk to you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]